Saturday night in Donald Trump has more
balls in the air than a juggling nudist
he's got North Korea the midterms ms-13
speaking of those fine chaps let's begin
with a quiz an ms-13 thug just got
sentenced to 40 years in jail for crimes
involving a murder of a teenager quick
question
what was his gang nickname animal animal
animal imagine that it wasn't fluffy
cuddles or captain snuggle puss and you
wonder why Trump's numbers keep rising
like Chris Matthews blood pressure
because he's right he's targeting
animals and they're parsing words so
imagine that your house is on fire and
your neighbor calls the police because
you were yelling fire too loud that's
the media when it comes to ms-13 now
check out the response to Trump pulling
out of the North Korea summit the
surprise cancellation of a planned
summit with kim jungeun is a stunning
turnaround today President Trump
canceled the June 12th summit with North
Korea's Kim jong-un it is pretty
stunning isn't it well if you're shocked
by that then you're probably shocked
every day by your own feet oh my god
where did these come from fact is this
occurs in negotiations and all Trump
does is negotiate I'm sure at his own
funeral he tried to cut a deal with the
grave digger of course the media could
only see the bad in Trump and with North
Korea it comes in two flavors mock Trump
for staying in mock Trump for pulling
out there by Trump II oh they want it
both ways no wonder America rates the
press only slightly higher than gout but
media anger media anger is derived from
a delusion that they can't shake Trump
is evil and or stupid but never ever
write this delusions getting worse if
only we had a delusion stripper a single
page letter with worldwide implications
the meeting is cancelled president
from scuttling his much-anticipated
summit with North Korea's Kim jong-eun
Tom this whole thing is headed for
disaster Donald Trump won't stop until
he destroys the whole country you sure
maybe it's not as bad as you always
think of course I'm sure that's what
they said about Hitler this president is
worse than ms-13 dude seriously you're
not living in reality you need the
delusion stripper what's that
quant follow me actually a very serious
situation
hit'em fella this president is
authoritarian you've just been hit by
the delusion stripper feel any different
now no he has been president for over a
year what is that thing the delusion
stripper is a retrofitted garden hose
that uses laser technology to hit you
directly in the face
you'll be so stunned by the precisely
calibrated 33 degree water your
delusions about the president will be
gradually to drift away working yet I
can't feel my face that's the
hypothermia setting in but how do you
feel about mr. Trump you mean the
president who stood up to Iran and North
Korea
we get the delusion stripper today
available pocket-sized mop just an
excuse to spray water on top salut
so this summit snag should that bother
you no because it's Trump and he isn't
these guys see Trump knows when to leave
the table Obama Hillary Kerry they can't
even find the table which is weird since
Kerry is made from a table besides it
wouldn't is a wooden fellow delayed
clapping and North Korea Olli already
wants back in but the media is still
obsessed with collusion while dismissing
the other story that at least one dude
was paid tons of money to spy on the
Trump campaign it's great watching the
media spin this first they say there's
no spying but if there was spying then
it's good spy it's like a spy hug but
it's definitely not spying which is why
we can't tell you the name of the not
spy so please don't blow his cover
because he's not spying here's a handy
video to help you follow the media's
take on all of this
I can watch that forever so the media is
tied up in knots as Trump rolls on here
he is at Annapolis on Friday we are
respected again I can tell you that we
are respected again the best way to
prevent war is to be fully prepared for
war we are witnessing the great
reawakening of the American spirit and
of American Mike
we have rediscovered our identity we
gained our stride and we're proud again
so did you hear that
that's Trump not just speaking to us but
to the world Trump speaks the language
everyone including our enemies
understands how do you know this because
it pisses off the very people who can't
do it meaning the media Trump says
America first
the Brits get it Russia gets it China
gets it everyone but CNN gets it the
message America is no longer the world's
welcome mat for them to wipe their shoes
on if you say walk softly and carry a
big stick
to do that you got to show the stick now
and then and so Trump is hijacked the
bullhorn before it was always Hollywood
that transmitted our values to the world
it said we were guilty oppressors not
anymore
America's Got a new spokesman so it's no
longer hi we're America and we're sorry
it's hi we're America deal with it
[Applause]
let us welcome tonight's guest
he got bin Laden to really open up
former Navy SEAL Rob O'Neill warning
labels writer and comedian Chris freed
she puts the cat in cat lady National
Review reporter cat Tim his favorite
dessert is Baked Alaska literally the
entire state baked former WWE Superstar
Maggie Kairos alright was Trump wrong to
call up the meeting with Kim jong-un
absolutely not he should have done
exactly that because he knows how to
negotiate from a position of strength
and that's what you'd do I mean he even
got them to to blow up their nuclear
arsenal and then he pulled out yeah
which is awesome yeah I think I mean
it's not his first this is not the first
deal he's made he wrote a best-seller
called part of the deal not part of
Benghazi so he actually you know he
shortened right away that he has he has
the power he can pull out Kim jong-un
really wants back and I'd be willing to
bet that that high-level government
officials probably looking at the
business end of like an anti-aircraft
gun at this point Kim Jong is not happy
with him and Kim jong-un wants this just
because he likes the being famous yeah
yeah he's gone he's now on the world
stage really and a lot of people don't
like that but the fact is sometimes you
got to bring people onto the stage in
order to change them I believe I don't
know there's only there's a lot more to
it but just simply backing away one time
in the liberal media was all over this
yeah I felt and they they they would
rather not have world peace than to have
trump succeed yeah but him pulling out
it's like just to take a wrap off this
is this not negotiation worse it's no
real negotiation well that's true Chris
it seems like the media has never bought
a car you know sweet question I was
still thinking about the delusion the
delusion stripper which I really enjoyed
but
I I always thought the delusion stripper
was stormy Daniels farewell words my
friend kiss I don't know I just feel
like we should be we should just feel
lucky that Trump doesn't use ms-13 as
the nickname for MSNBC I don't know how
does he not slip that yet he's not done
that and gone on like a whole spiel and
gotten in trouble but an idea because he
does watch believe it yeah well that my
main thought was on the animal stuff it
you know they they got to pick their
arguments and they you know and they
don't and this was a stupid one and now
it's like at the point where you know in
the midterms pretty much like every
Democratic candidate ad is going to be
like the Sarah McLachlan song over like
ms-13 like hurt victims and we need to
help these animals you know would be
like and you'd have to adopt one adopt
an ms-13 that's like 40 bucks a month
yeah they're all bleeding in barbed wire
I'm trying to get over Trump's wall or
whatever to socialize all right cat
address anything you want from my
marvelous monologue I think it's really
must be great to be one of these just
super anti Trump people cuz you don't
actually have to do any thinking at all
before you decide which side of
something you're on whatever side Trump
is on you're on the opposite side even
if the opposite side is a bunch of
people who rip other people's bodies
apart plan for Lin yeah you don't have
to even think about it all cuz if you
were thinking you might think oh I don't
really like Donald Trump but at least he
doesn't rip people's limbs off so that's
a little better
are we sure I believe that anybody's
brain actual brain would lead them to
that conclusion which can only lead me
to believe that brains aren't being used
at all in this situation it's true it's
actually irrationally based decisions
all emotion derived all right Tyrus you
think this deal with North Korea will
eventually be done yeah I think it's
already being done yeah I think there's
and I'm an entertainment you kind of are
and there's nothing worse than being to
being brought in the main stage than
going you know what we're not gonna do
it tonight I'm sorry
and that's basically what he did they
threw a little we're not we're not gonna
go if we don't get this he's like okay
wait no no like I do that to my kids all
the time
I don't want okay go to bed and that's
basically what he did and that's just
one on one being the big boy in the room
we have what they want they're starving
yeah the sanctions hurt no one's willing
to cross us to help them smuggling in a
little ship full of squid every six
months from China's not really getting
it done so they really need to have this
meeting with us and the sad thing is and
to his point where people just jump on
one side the other I think would be a
I'd like to see what happened right now
if Trump came out and gave a speech just
bashing Weinstein right now what would
they do what would that Morning Joe be
like yeah last night Trump er once Oh
[Laughter]
back to you we got to go but to your
point about like when you draw an
analogy to parenting Trump's letter to
Kim jong-un was a perfect version of
tough love it reminded me of exactly the
same tone those parents took when they
kicked that kid out the thirty year old
he says you've got to get a job you got
a certain any some money itself some of
your belongings it's exact Tony had with
him John you know things will go well if
you just listen to our advice he wasn't
he was complimentary - yeah which I mean
over a complimentary I think but but
he's just kind of showing him like look
it wasn't me it's you yeah that's the
worst breakup in the world we were like
I'm leaving I think that's a good idea
goodbye take care all right we still be
friends